تؤكد وحدة التحكم في المهمة أن الراعي
قد طهر البرج
[موسيقى]
ويبدو أننا واجهنا حالة شاذة
مع رحلة اليوم ،
حسنًا ، هذا الشذوذ الذي كان صاروخًا من أصل أزرق
يعاني من فشل في التعزيز
أثناء إطلاق صاروخ شيبرد الجديد
لحسن الحظ الآن لم يكن هناك
رواد فضاء  على متن هذا الصاروخ
حمولات علمية فقط ولكن هذا الفشل
أدى إلى إحباط نظام رأيت
المظلات هناك مما سمح
للكبسولة بالهبوط على طول الطريق
وانضممت إلي الآن كريستين
فيشر مراسلتنا الفضائية والدفاع ،
أعني أنك تنظر إلى  أن
كريستين تقولها يا إلهي ولكن في
نفس الوقت يبدو أنها عملت كما
كان من المفترض أن تكون في حالة كهذه ،
كما تعلم ، أعتقد أن السؤال الكبير
بالنسبة لي الآن هو ما الذي يفعله هذا بالنسبة
للأعمال ذات الأصول الزرقاء ، فهي صحيحة.
شركة خاصة شركة سياحة فضائية
أه ونعم ترى ما يحدث
هنا هناك مركبة فضائية جديدة من نوع Shepard تم
إطلاقها بالأمس وبعد ذلك
بحوالي دقيقة وأربعة  بعد ثوانٍ من
الرحلة ، يحدث شيء ما مع هذا
المعزز وهذا هو نفس الصاروخ
المعزز الذي أخذ جيف بيزوس ووليام
شاتنر إلى الفضاء ، يحدث شيء سيء
، ثم تنطلق الكبسولة الموجودة في الأعلى ،
لذا فإن الخبر السار هو
أن نظام الإجهاض في حالات الطوارئ يبدو أنه
قد نجح  ترى الكبسولة تهبط
تحت المظلات ، وبالتالي إذا كان الناس
على متنها ، فمن المحتمل أن
يكونوا بخير ولكن عليك أيضًا أن
تتساءل عما إذا كنت تعرف أن العملاء المحتملين الذين
يدفعون يرون ذلك ويعتقدون
أنك تعرف يا إلهي ، هل أريد فعلًا
أن أطير  في هذا الصدد ، لكن يجب أن أشير إلى
أن المركبة الفضائية شيبرد الجديدة
عادةً ما تكون نظامًا آمنًا جدًا تاريخيًا
، وقد طار هذا الصاروخ تسع
مرات دون مشاكل ، لذلك
تم التخطيط لإجهاض النظام ولكن بالتأكيد
لحظة مخيفة وتقوم إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية الآن
بالتحقيق